foreign
times when we had a negative balance in
our account and I couldn't buy food he
remembers a specific incident when all I
had was a potato and some cereal I think
his body is responding to a life of
Chaos
[Music]
I can't understand it I know you planned
it what's up everybody this is John with
the Dr John deloney show man I'm glad
that you're with us
greatest mental health and marriage and
relationship with parenting podcast ever
demised
[Music]
probably not but we're going with it I'm
so glad that you're with us uh on this
show we talk about everything and it's
not at you it's with you and we
grab a seat pull up a chair pull up a
bar stool and we figure out what's the
best right next move for you to make and
so I'm so glad that you've joined us if
you want to be on the show give me a
buzz
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k
and I love me some old Beastie Boys
sorry I probably shouldn't have started
the show that way but I like it all
right let's go to Kelly in Somerville
what's up Kelly
hi Dr John how are you
I'm fantastic how are you dude that's so
much better than I am I you just made me
go from to pretty good
oh God glad I could help that you're
fantastic is bringing us all up Kelly I
was in fantastic earlier Kelly has this
way of dragging everybody down but not
really that's not true that's not true
it's super true Kelly it's super true
hey I'm so glad that you called what's
up
me too so I'm trying to figure out
what's going on with my 11 year old son
and food he has some very weird
behaviors
um he makes grunting noises he blinks
rapidly like almost like facial ticks he
becomes fixated on food I'm always
asking what the next meal is and when is
it he gets upset when I say no to eating
extra desserts um
I'm wondering if it's food scarcity
issues and I'm trying to understand
um how to walk him through this without
shaming him I'm not sure what the best
way like to point out the noise to him
or is that going to make himself
conscious so I'm just trying to get
clarity on what is really the root of
his issues with food and how to walk it
out with him oh man thank you so you
mentioned
um
might be food scarcity related tell me
more about that is there something has
passed yes my ex-husband uh put us
through financial issues constantly and
there were often times when we had a
negative uh balance in our account and I
couldn't buy food I had no food and so
he remembers a specific incident when
all I had was a potato and some cereal
um to give him and he brought that up a
couple weeks ago and said I thought you
were just too lazy to go to the grocery
store he was around five uh when that
happened but he remembers it quite
vividly so I like wondering is that what
this is about is there something else
going on and what do I do yeah so
there could be a bunch of stuff here
um I'm gonna take a stab at it and I'm
gonna open this up to any therapist who
listened to the show and I hear from you
a lot a lot of you
um I'd love for your thoughts too
um here's my here's my guess just
listening just talking with you for a
couple of minutes okay Kelly
um well before I give you my guess let
me ask one more question was there any
abuse inside the home
probably call it a view abuse my husband
yelled a lot he would throw high chairs
when he would get angry or whatever was
around him he never physically touched
me or the kids but he had a lot of anger
issues okay how old's your little one
my youngest is
oh yeah you told me that you told me
that 11. okay
Okay so
let me say that there's several things
here there's the grunting there's the
ticks there which which is often a
body's way of just dealing with stress
or with anxiety right and so I don't
overthink that
um
that you I use that as a symbol as a
signal to me okay okay of a greater
internal distress
um so you have the yelling you've got
the food insecurity your son's got these
I'm gonna call them stories not Memories
um because he's now creating a new
Narrative of what happened inside of
what actually happened
and using that to reinforce his see what
I'm saying so it takes on a life of its
own to where his body is remembering
these stories less that they're a
play-by-play and in a couple years he'll
tell you another story and you'll think
I'm crazy I was there I know that didn't
happen and he will remember it as Vivid
right so it's about story right okay um
our bodies are our minds are story
making machines and they do that on the
back end of how we feel right so we have
these feelings in our bodies make
stories and
I think his body is responding to this
again I'm just throwing this out there
um I think his body is responding to a
life of Chaos
okay a life of
um not safe I'm not safe I'm not safe
and let's just take him at his word dad
was throwing furniture around
yeah Dad was probably radioactive even
when he wasn't throwing things around
and
um
somehow that narrative got transferred
over to you which is you're just too
lazy to even get me food
right
um or more importantly and this is where
I I'm going to say this out loud guilt
is okay shame is not okay here don't
don't take this on
but it's often uh it's not uncommon for
a kid to ask why didn't you get me out
of there
or why did this go on for so long and
they don't understand economics they
don't understand just understand safety
and they look to you and say that was
that's your one job right and so
and that now you have 11 year old and
you put on top of that there were
Knights y'all went hungry there were not
so he has become fixated he has become
compulsive when it comes to food
right so our tendency is to pathologize
the food we're going to count calories
we're going to say
um only this you need some more protein
in that meal you need some more I want
to try a different approach okay now I'm
gonna say this for a third time and I
won't say it again all you therapists
out there if you're listening this going
no you let me know right in and
um we will I'll make the I'll say hey I
was wrong on this and
um we'll we'll change it on the show but
here's what I want you to do I want you
to change his context to his
relationship to you
and to the entire food ecosystem here's
what that means okay
take him shopping with you and give him
five things to pick out
okay
let him be a part of that process and by
taking him to the store he's gonna see
how much food there actually is out
there
and that he has what we're giving him is
positive memories of an interaction with
an adult who's safe now
and with food
and we're also giving him teeny tiny
bits of controlled autonomy you have
choice
okay okay let him cook with you which I
know is the worst all right but he loves
to cook he loves it awesome buy him a
couple of cookbooks not internet recipes
buy them a couple of cookbooks or let
him pick out a couple of cookbooks what
are you interested in
and read them with him lay on his bed
with him and flip through the pages and
look at him we call him like uh it's
like food pornography or it's just like
these glossy beautiful stunning photos
of food that is not real but it just
looks so good
um lay on his bed with him there help
let him help you organize the fridge
like okay sit down okay where do you
think the milk should go where do you
think the egg should go I want you to
help me with this we're going to model
healthy eating so it may be that we're
gonna get sweets out of the house and
you say things like not Twinkies make
you fat or chips make it you say things
like when I eat chips I don't feel good
my thinking gets cloudy
um I just don't my tummy doesn't feel
good and he might say I think they're
great and be like oh they taste so good
but I feel better when I and then you've
got to model it
okay
um so we're gonna focus on on mood and
performance not on body composition see
what I'm saying I don't ever want him to
feel like he's broken
um and then I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
send you the questions for humans cards
with the kids and here's why I want you
guys to slow down at family meals and if
you're not having family meals
that's all got to change you guys okay
good you got to start doing that but I
want y'all to slow down so maybe it's as
a family we take one bite and then we
put our Fork down and then we're going
to answer one card and that is we're
just gonna learn we're gonna learn how
to slow down all of this is creating an
ecosystem of safety
and this is my sideways way of getting
you
to slow down and be highly intentional
and not being filled with guilt and
shame
because you are right
yeah oh yeah yes okay so I want you to
take these tools as an entry point into
a brand new relationship with your 11
year old
okay and
this is the hardest part
um
he knows that part of him is his dad too
right and that's going to haunt him
so he needs to know extra that he is
loved and that he's got value and that
he's smart and he's capable and all of
these things are a way to change the
entire environment around food
okay okay
um I also know the Lion's Share of This
falls on you and you probably don't have
a lot of free time you probably don't
have a lot of free extra money laying
around and I understand that this burden
disproportionately is something you got
to carry or if you heard me say
everything
you called to ask cat how do I help him
um have a better relationship with food
and just stop being so anxious and my
answer was you have to change your
behaviors see what I'm saying sure
because he's just a kid absorbing that
home
um ticks quite honestly unless they are
um they keep him from having normal
functioning like he is chirping really
loud or he's grunting to the point that
people in the restaurant are turning to
look
um I would give that a season 60 days 90
days working on these other things and
see if that doesn't begin to begin to
heal itself if it doesn't then it's time
to go you could talk to somebody
it sounds amazing okay I'm more worried
about like middle school and kids making
fun of him absolutely yes yes and it's
okay
to say not at the table
okay I don't even think he knows he's
doing it yes and it may just be parental
awareness hey you're grunting at the
table
what do you mean I'm grunting you're
making this noise
and it might just be somebody pointing
it out to him in love and you can do
with a smile on your face in a way that
he knows it's not I don't love you less
just stop doing that okay you know what
I mean okay
um and here's another thing it's okay to
say no
he needs to hear you say no and have
healthy boundaries so if he says I need
ice cream and you say we're not having
ice cream tonight
uh I'm the I'm the mom and we're not
having ice cream tonight we'll have ice
cream once a week on a special night if
fill in the blank happens
um and he gets mad if those are temper
tantrum's upset that's okay
he does when I he wanted two popsicles
and I said no and he got really angry
that's right
um that's okay that doesn't mean you did
something wrong and he has to
his anger's okay he's allowed to get
angry he's allowed to have his feelings
but he can choose to not have any more
popsicles for the rest of the week if he
if he says ugly things
right that's a choice he's making not
you're not punishing him with food
you're saying hey if you choose to yell
and scream and say something ugly or
throw something like like his dad was
doing he learned this by the way
um you're choosing not to have popsicles
don't do that because I love giving you
popsicles one of my favorite things
don't make that choice and then he's
gonna see yeah hold my beer I'll see if
she's really telling me the truth and
then you gotta decide are you actually
gonna do that or not is that fair right
yes absolutely I think that you can
transform this entire relationship
okay I may be way out to lunch and I'm
okay with being wrong on this if I this
was in my house this is right where I
would start
okay and by the way I'm a kid that grew
up with a lot of ticks
really yes a lot of them I was an
anxious kid and I was also an exhausted
kid
and so I blinked a lot I would grind my
teeth a lot I would pick my fingers a
lot like I did a lot I had a lot of
little ticks my friends used to make fun
of me I used to pop my neck a little bit
like I had all kind of weird stuff and
my buddies used to make fun of me about
all the time which by the way that was
their job they were just being kids
um but uh
I as an adult I've been able to track it
back almost directly to a lack of sleep
um and when I just get off the rails
with what I'm eating and I don't move my
body then man I start blinking again
real hard and I start cracking my neck
again all the things come back from when
I was a kid
um but it's it's not the tick itself
it's just a
it's it to me it's just an alarm system
okay so you probably need to get some
rest dude you're starting to you're
starting to starting to I caught my
clicks I'm just starting to click a lot
again
um and it's pretty rare that happens
these days but it does happen
wow well thank you I is that cool very
helpful yes this is amazing and you are
the greatest mental health podcast yes I
knew it if you say it long enough okay
hey uh but hear me say I'm a hundred
percent open to being wrong on this
um I would love it if you really gave
this a go for 30 days and you holler
back at me
back on the show and you can say I did
this and this and this and you're an
idiot just did not work or this did and
this didn't and here's why it may not be
um food for some parents it may be
clothes it may be I don't like these
these shoes feel weird on my feet it may
be any number of things that become a
moment of focus and control for a kid
because that's all they can control in
the world is this tiny little thing and
they're not doing it like to be mean
that's just their bodies have wrapped
themselves up in this one decision
because everything else in their life is
chaos and so if this works man that we
can be onto something is that cool yeah
yeah thank you so much your little one's
really lucky to have you
thank you are we done with the shame
yes promise I promise so dumb it's not
that easy I know but we're done right
we're done awesome you are the best
Kelly let me know how that goes and I
look forward to hearing from you hey
everybody we'll be right back
hey good folks Dr John deloney here can
we all just take a minute to take a deep
breath
ah there's a lot going on in our homes
our neighborhoods and across the world
and it might be stressing you out I know
I'm more stressed than usual but
remember we've been through Seasons like
this before and the best thing we can do
is to focus on controlling what we can
control
you can control your spending your
saving how much time you're spending on
electronics you can control your daily
habits and you can control making time
for sleep this one is easy to forget
especially when you're stressed but
sleep is key to taking care of your
physical and mental health and I have
found the key to great sleep is a great
mattress and that's why I love dream
Cloud mattresses they're so comfortable
and right now dream cloud is making it
easy to invest in good sleep with a
great deal 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 discount that's a
total of 849 dollars in accessories and
savings go to dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress today
all right we're back let's go to Sherry
in Salt Lake City what's up Sherry
how's it going Dr John we are partying
what are you doing
oh I am I am taking some time off of
work right now actually good for you and
by the way we I couldn't be further from
partying right now like I'm wearing a
button-up shirt like a [ __ ] it's fine
it's good so what's up
so
um it's so nice meeting you it's so nice
talking with you but uh uh I wish it was
underneath better circumstances
um what happened
well my question for you is is
how do you forgive yourself and move on
from the guilt and shame of past
mistakes
hmm that's a great question
I'm not great at this personally I can
give you all the academic answers I'm
not very good at it
um so the natural question I probably
wouldn't ask you this in a counseling
session in the way I'm going to ask it
now but it just makes for a better radio
Okay
um what'd you do
so
um almost three years ago I had a series
of Affairs okay
um two of which that were back to back
um one I'm actually currently with the
third one
um and my husband and I at the time were
just not doing well we we weren't
emotionally connected
um I had a ton on my plate in fact
looking back I I I'm like wow were we
ever emotionally connected
um at the time I was working full two
full-time jobs
um he was working full-time as well
um I was homeschooling our special needs
kids
um I was maintaining a house that was
you know cooking cleaning laundry
um you know just budgeting if the car
broke down that was on me to go and get
it fixed you know he would take the good
car to work I would have to somehow
figure out how to get the the bad car to
to the shop you know um I was actively
volunteering in the community I was you
know volunteering at my church
um and unfortunately we had also moved
to to a new area where I didn't have any
friends and
um you know we would we would talk about
things and I would I would say Hey you
know I really need some help
um and things would get better for maybe
a week and then they'd go right back to
maybe him providing about minimum effort
in in all these different areas
and it just warned me you know and I'd
have to say that I got in a pretty good
cycle of guilt and shame of not being
able to be successful you know as much
as I'd like to be in in these different
areas you know and
I
I don't like the way that things ended
um but they did end we we did end up in
divorce and I feel tremendous guilt of
of of breaking essentially and I know
these aren't you know it to me these are
not excuses these are this is just
context of sort of what happened and
you know and and
even though I know that we were heading
for disaster that communication was just
non-existent basically uh we weren't
hearing each other we weren't
we weren't supporting one another the
way that we should have
I just hate the way things ended between
us and what I'm finding is is that it's
it's blocking me from being able to give
a hundred percent in my current
relationship
you haven't dealt with the core issue
after all this time you still haven't
dealt with it
do you want to know what it is
do tell me
um
well there's two two big glaring things
and if you go watch this on on YouTube
when it comes out you'll see I just took
a bunch of notes while you were talking
um
two big glaring things here number one
you are trying to make me okay
but you keep speaking in terms of what
we were doing
and until me takes ownership of what me
did
there's never going to be congruence
does that make sense
and so all of your discussion of what
happened
was like you said it was a good context
but it was never
and then I went and did this and then I
went and did this not saying that I I
hundred percent know how you got there
right
but part of forgiving yourself is owning
and acknowledging reality and I don't
think you've done that maybe or maybe
you have and it's so painful because
you've got to deal with you
um that It's just tough to go there and
that leads me to number two which is the
overarching underneath and this is the
big entire neon sign is that cool
mm-hmm I don't think it's had anything
to do with your husband had anything to
do with your special needs kid
you didn't like who you were becoming
you didn't like who you had become
the first time you met somebody new
what how about this walk me through how
you met that person
um I I met them through work okay and
what does that mean so you just like
somebody you saw in the hallway and you
kind of laughed and it's kind of funny
uh just striking up conversations
um I was remote so you know striking up
conversations and you know the
conversations were very light
um I've had a lot of guy friends
throughout my life
um and so I didn't think anything of it
you know
and it I feel like it sort of snuck up
on me to tell me the truth
absolutely I don't think I don't think
for a second you set out to find a
replacement so take me take me from
light it's funny you think of a funny
joke or you send a funny emoji and he
writes back like that like lol like in
capital letters I could actually made
him laugh in real life and that felt a
little bit good and then like he
answered something in a zoom chat you're
like that guy's smart like walk me
through exactly how you ended up where
you were
foreign
the first time
honesty I think you know exactly
someone found me smart someone found me
funny
um someone wasn't demanding something or
expecting me to go above and beyond
what I had in me
and it was
refreshing to have someone
to uh
to sort of relax with
and what allowed you to relax
um because by the way this is all
happening on chat so most of this is
happening inside your head most of this
is a fantasy until y'all met up
yeah right like you were creating this
world I'll just cut to it because we can
do this for a long time
you're finally seen
through a filter of your own fantasy
and what's one what's if I distill it
all down what is one thing you felt
after all of this you're dealing with
special needs kid who you love but God
it's so hard you love your husband but I
just sitting on the couch again and
there's laundry baskets everywhere and
he's like oh by the way the car needs
oil change
what did what did you feel
um
what's the word underneath that spark is
perfect that's really close
alive
again
and so how did y'all meet up
uh work conference just had to had ended
up having to go to a work conference
um and you know we we planned it
beforehand okay
and how did you feel the next day
terrible
numb and almost like I I was
observing somebody else's life there you
go yeah because the fantasy filter went
away and suddenly it's
almost disassociative right
yeah because I am Sherry I'm not a
person who cheats I'm a mom I'm a I'm a
wife I'm a worker I'm not somebody who
cheats
yep
and now suddenly I found myself here
I'm the person that I judged and hated
there you go
was this person married too
I don't think so
okay
and what led to number two
uh first one stopped contacting the the
contact just went way down like you said
I think the fantasy just went away
and my ego was hurt
okay
and basically reached out to
the next person who would give me
attention okay but you realize the
person was a proxy for the feeling of of
being alive
yeah and so absolutely globally speaking
the
the challenge in any sort of romantic
relationship is
how do I how do how do how am I alive in
this relationship and how do we help
keep each other alive and that sounds
codependent and that's not what I mean
what I mean is how do we keep this fire
moving and not like it's it's fire not
like that but
how do I stay alive in this thing
and it's almost always through letting
your needs be heard and having strong
boundaries and having another partner
that's going to play along and you
didn't have that
and now you're in a situation was the
person you're with now were they with
somebody else
um they were at one point with somebody
else okay
so
the reason that relationships on the
back of Affairs are a mess is at the
core both of you know what the other
person's capable of
yeah
and it's very hard to put both feet on
the ground when you know
right
and so it takes and the worst part is is
trusting myself yeah that's what you're
saying now I've seen yes now I've seen
what I'm capable of and it's like I
didn't even it's it's like jumping out
of an airplane you know it's like I'll
never do that and then all of a sudden
you do and you're like well I can now I
can now I know I can and it's it's scary
as hell it is
because you don't know who you are
anymore
yeah and
you're trying to forgive something that
is a vapor because I don't think you've
sat and grieved
the loss of your marriage the loss of
the vision of what that was
because you married that guy y'all had
plans right
yep we had a lot of them yeah
and when you had a child with special
needs you love that kid and you grieved
that too because that wasn't what you
drew up for nine months right
not at all and then you had this life
that you had not planned and here it is
and
he went one degree left and you went one
degree right and you woke up a few years
later and you had no idea where that
dude was because y'all were both there
are the planet
right
so more like I had woke up one day and
realized I had plans and he was just
along for the ride yeah you know and
I but it's both in though because if I
sat down with him I could almost
guarantee you he would say dude she
didn't listen to a word I said
I just sat here and she ran through
everything because she was this she was
that had to be this way so I just
unplugged that'd be I almost be willing
to bet that's what he would say
yeah is that true
maybe
I don't know so
here's where we're gonna start the way
one you have to take ownership of what
you did the role you played
okay I gotta I have to own this I've got
to take blame out blame is contextual
and it's good but it doesn't solve any
problems doesn't help
yeah I gotta own what I did
I've got to own that I was capable of
doing something that I despised in other
people yet here I am
so the word is ownership ownership
ownership this happened period
the other thing is when you started
telling me
what happened
I wrote down you are still in disbelief
I can hear it in your voice
you still can't believe you did that yep
you cannot go back and edit sentences
that have already been written
unfortunately right yeah it is it is and
it's heartbreaking and sad and it is but
it's also the path forward to Healing
I can be a monster
and now I'm dedicated to not being that
person anymore
I wish it was more complicated than that
but it's not after you grieve this and
you take full ownership of your role in
this
the context again it's important but
it's it's over now now I've got to own
here's what I did and until you can say
those words out loud without I got a
close buddy who's very open I met my
spouse
um
uh through uh an affair is able to say
it with a period at the end of the
sentence and have a lot of guilt and
shame over it and here's who I have
chosen to become on the back end
beautiful that's what healing looks like
yeah yeah right so it's ownership it is
grieving and then it is asking yourself
that one terrifying frightening awful
scary question
what am I going to do now
who am I going to be now
so I'll ask you who are you gonna be
gosh possibilities are endless aren't
they they are
but you haven't even thought that you're
still beating yourself up
can I say something weird and I'm going
to get some mean comments on the
internet about me I don't think you're a
bad person
I don't
I think you I think you were tired
and I think you are absolutely Stone
lonely
and I think you and your husband ran
into a situation where neither of you
all had the tools and I'll say neither
of y'all had the character to go try to
get those tools but here we are
I don't think you're a bad person I
think you screwed up
yeah you know you know drum
we'll start crashing on you know in the
comments section dude you can't read
this stuff
if I can defend you for a second
um I was I was those people I I never
actually would verbally say out loud
you know you're a bad person but you
know it's I would have to say that
anything what I've learned through this
is to just have sympathy
you know well so my my I may have talked
about this one of the things that one of
the most important lessons my dad taught
me
um he was a homicide detective when I
was a kid in Houston so he saw some bad
stuff
and he said the hardest part of his job
was not the blood and the guts he said
the hardest part of his job
was sitting at a card table with
somebody who was an alleged murderer
and listening to their story
and sitting back in his little metal
folding chair realizing oh my gosh but
for two or three things that happened in
a day I'm that guy
I would have done that exact thing given
this situation on top of this one on top
of this one and then I went home and my
wife was with the mailman somebody's
gonna die right it all just happens
right in a row and all of a sudden as a
society we've gone murderer
and my dad said sitting across from a
Broken Man and feeling that Humanity
all of a sudden the labels don't make a
lot of sense because I'm looking at a
hurt guy right here who did Evil and
atrocity and has to be held accountable
for it make no mistake
yeah
um but
so I'm not I'm not gonna throw a rock at
you Sherry I'm snot
I'm not
um you know right it's there's no sense
in being like well you know what you do
yes you know more than anybody you know
the question is who am I going to be now
and not like what not what am I not
going to do I'm never going to cheat
again I'm that's like me saying I'm
never gonna eat jelly beans again that's
stupid all right that's gonna happen
um
it is creating a new identity that
begins with here's who I am
I'm a person who is impeccably
trustworthy
all the time forever
and that means you're going to fudge on
something you're gonna you're gonna tell
your your boss gonna be like hey you got
that reported and be like oh yeah I
emailed it to you let me go check and
see you know you didn't email it
you're going to circle back and say hey
I didn't email this here it is I'm sorry
you're gonna practice being a person of
impeccable integrity
and a part of that is I do not chat with
guys at work because I know what that's
like some people can do that some people
can have drinks on the weekend some
can't
and you Sherry cannot and that means for
the first time in your life you're gonna
have to figure out why you don't like
Sherry
and why flirting and male attention
is so important it's like oxygen to you
and that comes back from a long long
time ago is that fair yeah
so you're talking about a whole new way
of being
I mean that's easy enough right oh
simple yeah yeah I wanted to name my
book um how to change everything and my
wife was like that's too much that's too
much I'm not doing that I'm not doing
that
but here's the thing here so people ask
me like what do you mean when you say
practice here's what I mean
when a chat window pops up and you're in
Zoom or you're at a conference and some
guy sits by you and makes a joke and you
laugh and you scoot a little bit closer
or you intentionally bump your foot
against his
or you text back a funny joke
and then he texts back and you text back
it it's catching yourself right there
yeah
sketching stuff right there
and exhaling and saying this goes off
it's that simple and then you got to
live in that discomfort of I'm not
getting propped up by somebody else
right now that means I gotta go home and
deal with what's at home
and I gotta go home and deal with what's
in the mirror and that's so hard
you know what I mean yeah
are you willing to do that
absolutely
and uh this is going to be hard it may
not be with the guy you're with that may
not be the long-term play here
or y'all both might say
both of us didn't make good choices both
of us did things that were regrettable
and not good both of us hurt other
people we start cleaned here together
and I've seen that work great but it
takes both people being committed
yeah is he that guy
he is definitely that guy for real
I I don't
I don't know how
but I
I you know when you you do a lot of bad
things in your life and you you ask
yourself well I mean you you feel like
you don't deserve anything good because
you're not a good person you know but
for some reason
I I can't explain it but he saved me
from
from a lot of stuff
and
um he's willing you know and I think
that's one of the understandings that we
have
is that we know what each other are
capable of you know yeah but that's how
the US and Russia have gotten along for
a long time and it doesn't work in the
long term
we uh were able to have very Frank and
open conversations which is
you know it's it's difficult at times do
y'all have any secret do you have
secrets you keep from him no no okay no
we didn't we
we do not keep Seekers from each other
are you still in communication with your
ex
yes we're we're on we're in pretty
friendly terms
have you ever sat down with him and said
I'm sorry
absolutely how'd that go I've
he was very receptive he was
I heard it's even worse doesn't it yeah
makes you makes you feel even worse
about yourself it'd be fun if you flip a
table over it's like oh yeah and you can
feel Justified like yeah
exactly it sucks from the people we hurt
have super High character and integrity
doesn't it
kind yeah
um
here's your homework assignment are you
ready
okay I want you to write a letter that
begins dear Sherry
can you do that okay
and it will be the things that you're
disappointed Sherry did
it's going to be about the things that
you absolutely s just don't love About
Cherry
and then it's going to be in part three
of this letter
here's who Sherry's gonna be
a woman of impeccable Integrity I'm
going to be the best romantic partner
ever
my husband or my boyfriend or whatever
you want to call him he may have quote
unquote saved me but he's not my savior
yeah he pulled me out of the water but
it's my job to walk now
and so I am a person who's committed to
getting well I'm a person who's
committed to growth
I'm committed to being a light in my
community and that means I've got to
understand that I'm worth being loved
even though I did dumb stuff I'm worth
being loved
yeah will you tell Sherry that because
she's been needing to hear that probably
since she was a little girl
you promise because I like Sherry
yeah
okay I promise and I will say this again
to people watching and listening
we're not throwing rocks on this one
because for those of you listening to
statistically speaking this is a lot
more of you than y'all want to admit
and y'all may not have made the final
plans like Sherry did
but you thought about it you gotten
close
or your roommates with the person you're
married to and it's been a long time
[Music]
finding people to throw rocks at almost
never solves anybody's problems
look in the mirror and saying I'm gonna
make my home my marriage my parenting my
community a little bit better
that's where we start
Sherry I'm grateful for your bravery for
your honesty and for just calling and
saying I'm gonna lay it all out there
I'm grateful for you
ownership forgiveness grief and that
scary question who am I going to be now
we'll be riding with you Sherry thank
you so much we'll be right back
all right hey we're back I got this
direct message I'll just say it's from
Jack Jack if you're listening you know
who you are
um I'm super glad you reached out here's
what Jack wrote
I love your show John I'm a redneck
tough Midwest guy and I enjoy the heck
out of it dude I already like you jack
we're already we're already good friends
one thing I gotta ask
why in every episode you tell someone to
pick up a rock and drop it I tried it
and the whole time I think about how
stupid it feels instead of getting rid
of the grief am I doing it wrong
dude great question Jack thanks for
sitting that on the internet
um for sliding into my DMs I think this
other kit nope there's no nope that's
not what they said okay
um thank you for sending me an
electronic message from the Midwest Jack
um okay a couple things
carrying her throwing a rock picking up
and throwing it is not going to heal
your grief okay
when I tell somebody to go to the store
and buy a brick buy a cinder block and
write on it what's this thing you're
carrying around
whether that's hatred for somebody rage
for somebody an inability to forgive
yourself
I want you to carry it
past the point where it's comfortable
obviously don't get injured don't do
anything it's gonna
cause you harm
but I want your body to feel how heavy
this is
I want you to carry it around to the
part that your shoulders are heavy your
hands are heavy it's it's scraping on
your hand it's just heavy
and then I want you to do walk all the
way you can to the back corner of your
backyard for some of you living in
condos or apartments that's not very far
walk you may go out to a park for some
of y'all in a big place it might be a
long walk
but the whole thing is a miniature
pilgrimage but from
where I am right now to I am going down
and I'm going to set this thing down and
when you set it down
and you stand up
that lightness that freedom feeling
I want your body to get a tiny little
glimpse of what it's going to feel like
when you're not carrying around somebody
else's anger when you're not carrying
around somebody else's bad decisions
that they made that you still hate that
drunk driver that took your dad 14 years
ago or seven years ago
that anger in that rage is not helping
your dad come back it's not further
punishing the drunk driver it's just
making your life
more miserable
and so Jack dude is just a metaphor for
how heavy these things are that we carry
we don't realize
that the poison that we carry has a
physiological consequence every time we
spin up and think up about that drunk
driver our body starts the threat
response system again and let's dump
cortisol and adrenaline into the
bloodstream and get this sucker fired up
again because we gotta fight or we gotta
run from something and there's no way to
fight anymore there's nobody to run from
you become Your Own Worst Enemy
and so Jack uh it's just simply a
metaphor walking out your backyard and
just picking up a rock and being like
I looked at a bad website and then
throwing it on the ground that's not the
point the point is to say I'm carrying
this thing around and I want to stop and
it also is not going to assist with your
grief at all in fact it will amplify
your grief
it will free you up to finally feel
I'm trying to think sometimes whenever I
go rucking I've got my goruck bag and
I've got it filled with some weights and
I would go walk it's so heavy and all I
can feel are the straps in my back all I
can feel is my shoulders tense and me
hunched oh it's just so heavy
I don't feel how much my feet hurt and
how much my knees hurt
until I take it off I drop that thing
and then I realized oh that's how tired
I am oh that's my knees or girl I need
to stretch whatever the thing is
then I can finally feel my entire body
but until I take that backpack off I'm
just feeling where those straps are
digging in and so we often carry around
anger or rage and we think it's just
them it's just them it's just it's us
we're the ones paying the price for that
hatred that rage that frustration that
lack of forgiveness it's us
and so really it's just an exercise it's
a metaphor
um the feedback I've received has just
been second to none
folks who said okay I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna set it down and when it
pops back in your mind the next day you
can be like nope I put that down in the
backyard I've got a place where I put it
down it's like going to a funeral I've
got a point when I said goodbye to my
grandmother I got a point when I said
goodbye to my kids
we had a funeral and we said goodbye
it's that process so
um thanks for your question man I love
you dude and I hope you come visit us
here in Nashville sometime I'd love to
um I was gonna say buy you a cup of
coffee but it's free here in the lobby
if y'all ever want to come visit but
um thank you so so much for that
question Jack everybody you got
something in your past It's haunting you
that you've done that was done to you
try it
go buy a cinder block pay the money go
through the process buy it put a piece
of duct tape on it or a piece of masking
tape on it write down what happened
just carry it around with you
15 minutes 20 minutes some of you may
only be able to carry it for two minutes
right
and then take it somewhere where it's
going to sit down forever
maybe you go on a hike with it out in a
in a park and you carry it out into the
woods and you set it down and say this
is where this this this is where this
gets left forever
and then every time you think of it in
the future you'll be like it's already
over there give that a shot let me know
how it goes we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right hey um Kelly you said you went
down a skid row rabbit hole yeah I heard
a song yesterday on the way home what
was it I think 18 in life was on what a
great time and then I was just like Rick
wait a minute so then I started pulling
up on Spotify more skid row and that's
that's a pretty good uh Rabbit Trail to
be on I think Slave to the Grind is one
of my favorite records ever ever I just
remember being a kid sitting in the back
of my dad's car while he was gone oh man
that record
ah and in all seriousness top four or
five songs ever ever
skid Rose I Remember You The Greatest
Ballad of all time it's right up there
with Something to Believe In about
poison
but I gotta go with I remember you
but Dave the snake Sabo and Rachel Bolin
skid Rose I remember you goes like this
woke up to the sound of pouring rain the
wind wind would whisper and I think of
you all the tears you cried they called
my name and when you needed me I came
through you paint a picture of the days
gone by When Love went blind and you'd
make me see and I'd stare a lifetime
into your eyes
so that I knew that you were there for
me time after time you were there for me
remember yesterday walking hand in hand
love letters in the sand
I remember you
through the sleepless nights in every
endless day
I want to hear you say I remember you
see you soon everybody
[Music]